hey what's up and welcome to the
gamespot stage right here at e3 2015
we've seen a bunch of really great games
today a bunch of interesting developer
characters but I'm very very proud to
introduce one of my heroes especially
during my teenage life and not only in
terms of my things I was up to outside
of the house but also the things I was
up to inside there's mr. Tony Hawk thank
you so much and for joining us today at
Tony Hawk's Pro Skater 5 it seems funny
to even save five considering that you
got all the way up to eight nine ten
have one what we're talking about here
is basically a sort of a return to the
the formative years of the Tony Hawk
experience tell us about this game the
challenge too many challenges the way
that the control mechanisms and but
we're bringing it to the new generation
of consoles so obviously the graphics
are much much better the motion is
better and the online element is a whole
new thing for us so we are able to have
people create their own parks share it
with the world and have up to 20 people
playing with you all across the globe
it's crazy an online stuff has been
involved in other tony hawk games I
remember there was PlayStation
exclusives for some of the online stuff
and xbox fans wanted to get online so
much it actually hacked it into their
system link and has I'd always been a
sort of a push for you guys because Tony
Hawk is such a it's almost like a
competitive type game I remember playing
with my buddies and I'd have a go on
warehouse in mvi all right that's always
been an element is definitely
multiplayer but but the multiplayer that
we were more used to was with same two
people on the same console with a split
screen and we obviously had online play
in the past but but it just wasn't
hadn't come of age like it has now so
the fact that we can utilize that and I
mean we can we can offer the game
digitally we can offer downloadable
content like all those elements were not
in part of the THPS series originally
and let's look at some of the gameplay
here you guys debuted this I know I'm
Geoff Keighley stage for a YouTube III
some familiar looking places here yeah
well we got the some of the old fairy
school and the warehouse
a little bit of the hangar in there and
we have new elements to where you can
you know get electrocute your board or
set it on fire and and actually blade
literally blazed a trail behind you
that's excellent are you guys gonna have
em in the two-minute ones collect likes
collecting skies yes would you collect
the secret tape do people have seeker
anymore yeah well maybe you a thumb
drive yeah man it just doesn't have the
same ring to it not quite know what
about the skaters you're gonna have in
there because obviously the world of
skateboarding has changed a lot it's
about to say it's changed a lot you're
still doing it's been well like Andrew
Reynolds also has been skating actively
since our release and yet still killing
us so he and I there are the two
original characters in the game but we
have a new lineup i mean i think it
represents currents that the state of
skateboarding currently aaron homoki
jaws who's considered sort of them the
big stunt man these days Nyjah Huston
who is the winningest skater of our
generation yeah Lizzie are manto who I
think is the best female a transition
skater Leticia Bufoni David Gonzalez
it's a solid crew so I'm really proud of
him are you gonna dive into the
unlockable characters stuff as well yes
that was is that all you're gonna say
what they're known as secret characters
so had to keep them a secret all right
maybe office maybe some certain police
men the weird of spider-man showed up
again who knows that's not impossible
okay all right we'll have to stay tuned
bye guys and then in terms of the levels
themselves at this stage you've got this
just massive collection of fan favorites
to pull from between the downhills stuff
and like iconic ones like school in
school to the hangar like Venice Beach
in a way i remember playing these games
in Ireland and I'd never been to America
before and then the first time I was in
America was in Los Angeles and the first
thing I did was go down to venice beach
and I was like holy sure that's pretty
cool yeah it's actually kind of like
that and are you gonna be diving back
into the old stuff mostly are you gonna
be making new levels oh its a mix there
are some classic levels in there and um
some new one like the barracks is a
famous escape facility that's that's the
training grounds for this game yeah just
here right here in LA yeah but what we
are relying on people wanting to create
their own
and I like I said I think that's a big
element that we were missing before so
the idea that someone can create a skate
park that we hadn't even thought of and
share it online and you know strangers
could come and join them for a session
yeah create a skater our great escape
park rather I think in the second game
again really increase the longevity of
the experience so yeah and in terms of I
guess the the sort of the wider
conversation about Tony Hawk this is a
franchise that we're seeing return we've
seen Activision dude with guitar er we
just had them up here yeah again it's
it's it's almost like the good old days
I guess and what's it like to you seeing
Tony Hawk's Pro Skater return into THPS
sort of format because stuff got real
big with underground and sort of turned
into like a viva la bam sorry yourself
and then it almost it grew with the way
open world games were going what what
does it feel like to be sort of compact
that's exciting to return to what made
our series popular in the first place i
I'm hugely proud of all the games to be
honest but but the idea that it this is
representative of what put us on the map
and we're sticking with that that same
formula for the fans I mean this really
is an answer to the calling of so many
fans of the series over the last four
years I can't even count how many you
know tweets and messages I've gotten
about just wanting that formula and so
we're bringing it and the neversoft
worked on the game for the sort of the
the the most time you guys been working
a robo moto at the HD game came out I
think it was a 2012 yes stage and that
game came out to sort of a mixed
opinions it was some people who said it
was very good some people said it didn't
feel as tight as the old games what's
been like working with Romo Robo moto
considering this is the one that kind of
really matters this is like uh it's one
it's felt that that we definitely have a
reverence for the series and and it has
felt that important and we've actually
consulted with some former neversoft
developers on wow so I feel like all the
pieces are in place for this one too to
satisfy and and hopefully exceed
expectations of the original fans an
interesting thing whenever we talk about
old franchises returning it's kind of
weird to talk about it in terms of
sports games because we never say that
about
notta norvor fifo yeah and in many ways
in action spray you blazed the trail and
you know who I'm waiting for the return
of track and field oh yeah yeah could be
yeah if you think your fingers can go
hope yeah I can't do that anymore break
all your joysticks yeah it's interesting
because in a way you're you know that
we've all these people here watching of
massive fans of the games I'm sure but
there's a whole new generation like I
grew up playing those games loving them
and I was eleven twelve thirteen the
whole way through college but there's a
whole generation of kids who might never
have plays the pro skater games and do
you think you're also sort of going for
them yeah absolutely we want to we want
to share it with the whole new
generation I think there are a lot of
people plenty of people that played our
games that are now parents themselves
and share with their kids there's some
kids are just going to discover for the
first time and think it's a whole new
thing and I'm proud of how it represents
skating so I I hope they find it and we
talked earlier today for a feature that
will be on gamespot in a month's time or
so and sort of wider about the history
of skateboarding video games and the
influence that your franchises
particular had on I guess sort of
translating the the vocabulary of
skateboarding to the world if we can
sort of dive back into that for a little
bit and for you looking back at games
like Tony Hawk's one two and three
you're somebody who's actually involved
in developing his games you're not just
like tiger woods golf and just speak to
what it was like being involved being
responsible for the skateboarders video
game because I must have been like
almost like a burden to get it right it
was but but it was a it was a
responsibility I took out myself because
when we first started the game it did
feel very much like something that was a
test yeah and so I play video games my
whole life I always appreciated this
skating was included in video games but
I never thought it was represented that
well and so if I had the chance to do it
i really wanted it to be authentic i
wanted to to represent the culture and
the lifestyle the music the looks the
the skating the way it feels and so I
dove in headfirst and and I and when we
first released the game I just thought
it would be something that skaters would
enjoy and maybe it would inspire
to start playing video games that's
really the goal of what I you know that
first and foremost I wanted the skaters
to be happy with it so it's definitely
just a pressure i took on myself and I
the the the idea that inspired a
generation to start skating or take an
interest in skating was kind of a happy
accident yeah it's incredible to think
that I guess video games in so many ways
allow people to do things that they they
can't do in real life travel to places
they can tour or engage in experiences
that they otherwise wouldn't have the
difference with this was that people
could go out and spend 100 bucks on a
skateboard theory like that yeah they
could go try 36 foot crooked grind all
day long if they want to I've only got a
couple of questions left cuz I know
you're a busy man here at e3 when you're
selecting the skaters for these games
and also when you're selecting the bands
who get their their music in a Tony
Hawk's Pro Skater game do people just
like throw their hands up and her life
just like me me me me me but yeah and
especially with the advent of social
media it means it's our first series
I've actually found a couple bands like
through Twitter and work you know that
we're very loudly and consistently
trying to get my attention and I if you
know I went and looked at their meter
heard their music and not maybe this
will fit and so there are couple bands
we've discovered in that way and put in
the game there's some classic punk stuff
that I feel like there was there's so
much to choose from from from my
generation yeah that we didn't use in
the previous game so some of that
there's there's new stuff I mean I I
feel like there's as much pressure to
have a good soundtrack almost as there
is to have a good game excellence when
will we be able to get our own hands on
Tony Hawk's Pro Skater 5 and I wat
platforms later this year and well first
it'll be released on xbox one ps4 and
then the older systems right after that
awesome tony hawk's thank you so much
for coming on and talking to us really
appreciate it very much looking forward
to getting back on the skateboard
because God knows physically I'm not
quite I don't know why I'm saying
physically your approach it by your late
40s and you're still doing it yeah thank
you for saying my approaching sorry I'm
hearing but I want the facade that I'm
approaching them I thought I've got more
gray hair than than
than anyone twice my age so don't worry
about it I thanks so much for your time
again thank you I stay tuned to the
gamespot stage we'll be back in just a
little bit of KJ tofu nay and here's new
game for the xbox one
you